guillaume martin merci d'être avec nous
en direct sur rt france pour commencer
peut-être une réaction aux propos de
jean luc mélenchon que l'on vient
d'entendre
ils demandent un changement de
comportement de la police
il trouve que la police aujourd'hui est
dix fois trop barre mais comment
réagissez vous à ces propos que le nous
venons d'entendre qui est certain c'est
qu'il ya un processus qui est long
ancien déjà d'armement surarmement des
de la police en france il ya quinze ou
vingt ans la police n'étaient pas armés
comme elle l'est aujourd'hui elle
n'était pas avec des équipements aussi
agressif que qui peuvent être ce qu'ils
ont aujourd'hui et que effectivement ça
incite pas à l'apaisement il à vis des
populations qui par ailleurs sont plus
particulièrement visées par un centre de
contrôle de comportement aussi pour
certains peuvent être le dégradant lundi
alors pour revenir cette manifestation
de ce samedi le rassemblement a été
interdit pour des raisons sanitaires par
la préfecture de police pour autant le
constate ces derniers jours les
manifestations semblent tolérer comme
celles par exemple des policiers hier
finalement est-ce qu'on n'est pas un peu
dans un flou juridique s'est il est
évident qu'on est dans un flou juridique
et qu'en réalité c'est moins une
question juridique munitions politiques
et le fait est qu'il ya des
manifestations parce qu'il ya la volonté
d'exprimer à un roger des violences
policières et que ce rejet les massifs
et face à ça il ya deux possibilités ou
bien on réprime les manifestations l'on
verra ce qui se passera
aujourd'hui on a vu comment ça s'est
passé le 2 juin dernier
ou bien on encadre de telle sorte que
chacun puisse exprimer sa position a
exprimé sa colère dans le cadre d'une
manifestation qu'on espère la plus la
plus sereine possible
vous parlez des roues je note quand même
permettez moi c'est un peu moins en
effet d'une remarque qu'il ya quand même
deux poids deux mesures entre les
manifestations qui peuvent être
organisées contre les violences
policières et les manifestations et
c'est un bien grand mot
deux policiers qui ont la possibilité de
ce dû s'incliner devant les grilles du
place beauvau là où les autres
manifestants sont cantonnées dans l'est
l'est parisien bien loin des lieux de
pouvoir et de décision
vous parliez justement de cette
manifestation du 2 juin dernier on le
rappelle vingt mille personnes étaient
réunies devant le nouveau palais de
justice de paris
est-ce qu'il n'aurait pas fallu autorisé
ces manifestations pour mieux les
encadrer et finalement c'est ce que vous
nous dites c'est évident c'est évident
qu'on savait qu'il y allait avoir du
monde il ya eu du monde plus encore
peut-être même que tout ce qu'on peut ce
que les organisateurs pouvaient pouvait
attendre et à partir de là il y avait un
choix logique et politique on est au
delà de juridique qui est de savoir
qu'est ce que l'on fait c'est
manifestants qui vont venir de toute
façon ou bien on les réclame ou bien on
les nas ou bien on les gaz c'est à dire
ou bien on met en oeuvre la doctrine
classique du maintien nord avec beaucoup
de guillemets qui est à l'oeuvre à paris
depuis un certain nombre d'années
désormais ou bien on change de méthode
et on essaye de faire que les choses se
passent au mieux
nous verrons comment les choses se
dérouleront cet après-midi dans les rues
de paris mais je crains que compte tenu
des déclarations récentes notamment du
préfet l'allemand tout ne se passe pas
malheureusement aussi bien qu'on
pourrait l'espérer
c'est à dire que vous craignez des
débordements et des affrontements avec
les forces de l'ordre cet après midi
qu'est ce qui vous fait penser à cela
ce qui me fait penser à cela c'est le
spectacle de hanau et nuit
manifestations qui se déroulent dans les
airs dans les rues de paris
et qui sait si systématiquement ou
presque se termine par des affrontements
avec la police avec eux à un dispositif
du maintien dans qui extraient moins
agressif avec bien souvent des
manifestants sont des manifestants qui
sont assez dans les rues de paris sur
les places les lieux de les lieux de
rassemblement créant une atmosphère de
tension
si vous ajoutez à ça quelques centaines
de bombes lacrymogènes
jeter sur sur les manifestants
créer une situation de débordement et
puis le débordement arrive il est
prévisible et il arrive et à partir de
là ça donne la possibilité à ceux qui le
veulent de dénoncer d'abord et avant
tout la viola
des manifestants pour essayer de masquer
la revendication de frappes majeures de
ces manifestants qui en l'occurrence et
celle de dénoncer la violence
systématique endémique quotidienne de la
police vis à vis d'un certain de deux
jeunes en particulier dans ce pays
est-ce que vous avez noté une évolution
des forces de l'ordre de la manière de
pratiquer le maintien de l'ordre ces
derniers jours lors de ses dernières
manifestations par rapport aux
manifestations de l'année dernière des
gilets jaunes
bon ça a été moins violente que les fois
que les fois précédentes encore une fois
je
l'expérience montre qu'il ya plus de
chances que ça dérape qu'autre chose
compte tenu de ce qu'ils sont au niveau
de la prise de décision au niveau de la
préfecture de police de paris qui
revendique une méthode et une doctrine
d'une internaute qui est agressive
espérons que ce ne soit pas le cas
aujourd'hui donc ce ne soit plus le cas
à l'avenir
ceci étant les déclarations récentes
montrent qu' il ya une bénéfique à une
vraie difficulté à ce sujet il est clair
que il y a un souci de la part du
gouvernement et la préfecture de police
qui apprécie les situations comme tout
on est qui voit bien qu'il ya un vrai
sujet était une vraie tension sur la
question des violences policières et
peut-être aura l'intelligence de
comprendre que ce serait mieux que je
dépanne que les manifestations se passe
le mieux possible et que on n'use pas
des méthodes agressives qui sont celles
qui ont pour habituellement dans les
manifestations à paris en particulier
merci beaucoup guillaume martin d'avoir
répondu à nos questions j'appelle que
vous êtes avocat et membre de
l'observatoire parisien des libertés
publiques